welcome back I'm joined by my well super
pack tonight talk to the contributor
Esther Kracker the comedian podcas of
James Bar the political journalist AV
Santina from the United States the
YouTuber H Davis well welcome to all of
you so I want to start with this uh big
fuori in the House of Commons today
because well it was basically all about
this show in a way because Kia stama
opened up by attacking the Prime
Minister about his admission to me that
they failed to hit their waiting this
targets and then he went on to mock him
about the bet that we made for charity
over the Rwanda plan um but then things
turned what many think to be quite ugly
because the Prime Minister said this and
it's a bit Rich Mr Speaker to hear about
promises from someone who's broken every
single promise he was elected on I mean
I think I counted almost 30 in the last
year pensions planning peerages public
sector pay tuition fee Child Care second
referendums defining a woman although
although In fairness that was only 99%
of a urn up all the weeks to say that
when briana's mother is in this
chamber shame parading as a man of
integrity when he's got absolutely no
responsibility well the contentious
element of that is of course that
Brianna J's mother Esther was up in the
G now it turned out she wasn't there
actually at the moment that this joke
was made by the Prime Minister he would
say a pointed remark making a point at
Kia st's expense but AA it's caused a
lot of furor this falling out saying
that it was very callous inappropriate
and so what's your
view I I'm I'm really upset about it I'm
sad I'm sad for her mother and I'm sad
for every transperson in this country
that had to witness that today I think
the worst for those who don't know her
mother was a transgender girl who was
brutally killed by two complete psychos
and it was her daughter Bri yes Brian G
was yes was killed and she was she was a
transom um but you know what's really
upsetting about this is that we don't
even afford trans people dignity in
death I think that the way that that is
going to now be marked in Hansard in the
Parliamentary book forever I think that
is shame on the country I'm sad to hear
it James yeah I agree I think it's
utterly shameful it's just disgusting
I'm so annoyed with riak he has
absolutely no Backbone in the same week
that he made a lazy bet with the devil
about refugees he's now
now made a joke exactly he's now made a
joke about another minority and it's
just disgusting well okay you're not
calling me the devil uh for one I don't
have horns um but secondly um I don't
know Esther I think I'm missing
something here I think the thing is can
we get some perspective here Richi sunak
has made this comment about K being
unable to define a woman many times and
the only to be clear about the
background of that K stama spent most of
the last two
years refusing to say what
then eventually saying women could have
penises then he said well actually 99%
ofen don't have a penis meaning that 1%
do and the one time that he chooses to
defend himself or himself on his record
is the unfortunate time that Brianna
ji's mother is in is in the comment I'm
sorry look it was in poor taste given
the circumstances but at the end of the
day it's a very valid point horrible
something it's a very valid because it's
a very valid point because the thing is
this whole issue about you know trans
rights doesn't just you know is not
based on one thing it's also based on
women feeling their like their rights
are no but that's the point that's being
made these are
politicians issu hang on hang H
Westminster and gossip Fest nobody is
disputing that trans people have rights
to fairness and equality yes they are no
they're not here's what I'm disputing
I'm sorry but it's 100% of women do not
have a penis let's just start with a
biological fact can you imag this was
not an attack on this poor woman who
lost her daughter had nothing to do with
her whatsoever this was an attack on
Karma's inability to actually stand up
for women's rights and to say
unequivocally that women do not have a
penis which by the way is
a it is standing up for women's rights
the moment you try to prend women have a
penis you are destroying women's rights
that's trans women are women no they're
not okay and I'm sorry unless you are
I
how having your skull woman is a
biological female you not understand it
I'm sorry unless you're you're someone
who's who who's having your child having
to sh your female child having to share
a bathroom with a biological man you
will never understand what it means for
us to sit there and pretend like trans
you're drilling it
down you have women that have had
hysterectomies are they no longer women
let me bring bring pearls wasting
patiently pear across the pond um lot of
people clutching their pearls about all
this Pearl ironically but I just think
that in the end what Rishi sunak did was
in a list of things that he claimed his
opponent had had made urns on he made
the completely valid point if you take
it in its in its isolation that actually
it was ridiculous to pretend that a
percentage of women have a penis and for
that he's now being branded
transphobic what do you think of
that well number one I can't believe you
guys are grown adults arguing about what
a woman is or like I it blows my mind
number two um I have family members that
died of obesity I still support people's
right to make jokes about being fat life
is hard get over it she love and number
three um you know I'm a semi-pro athlete
here in in the UK you know I I I play I
play sports in London and I've actually
had to deal with some of the
consequences of women
being women's spaces
being you know having men come in them
and like you know I had a tournament
last spring where there was a whole team
full of men you know just dressed up as
women so is that
fair be more threatened by your your
your recent tweet where you said that
16y old girls were hotter than 26y old
women if I was a woman and I saw that
tweet and I saw you in a space I'd be
terrified then why aren't you why aren't
you protesting why AR aren't you
protesting the age of consent laws in
the UK if you're really outraged all all
you guys do is try to find one thing out
of context and you're changing the
subject really when we're here to talk
about is it all right for him to make
jokes can make jokes but he certainly
wasn't here's the point here's the point
he certainly wasn't trying to make a
joke at the expense of this poor girl
who got murdered or with her mother
there deliberately trying to uh score
some point with her there he was purely
making the point which he's made
repeatedly that when Kia starma can't
say what a woman is that is ridiculous
and I agree with him about that and I'm
not sure that the Prime Minister should
be branded transphobic for not thinking
that a woman has a penis well why do you
think that would you not think that all
of this narrative feeds into the hate
that is in this country absolutely you
not think that because it's not hateful
Su biolog among trans people where do
you I have always supported for example
trans people's rights to fairness always
right I've been repeatedly called
transphobic myself for thinking that a 6
fo4 biological male who becomes a
transwoman athlete and starts
demolishing biological females in a
swimming pool and breaks all records or
wants to be on the Olympic team
depriving a woman of a place and so on
that I think that is ridiculous
transphobic think I'm supporting and
defending women's rights similarly Richi
sunak thinks it is absurd that a
political leader in this country should
think that a any woman
can I can I pose you that it's quite
possible that Rishi sunak is a terrible
politician and he didn't even understand
the attack I'm sorry that's given to
well half of his party didn't understand
it K badok said this every murder is a
tragedy we can all agree none should be
trivialized by political Point scoring
as a mother I can imagine the trauma
that es guy has endured it be shameful
of starma to link his own inability to
be clear on the matter of sex and gender
directly to her gr and that's that's the
point here's here's the we have turned
Westminster into a gossip Fest because
Rishi sunak has made this point about
K's inability to talk about what a woman
is for literally months and we all
understood it but suddenly when there's
an opportunity to score cheap political
points and to make the link between that
and this poor lady Brianna ji's mother
suddenly we're now all outraged by it
this is not the first time R I said it
and we know it but because we've decided
to turn our politicians from from actual
politicians who have a job to do to
basically reality stars we we figing
ignorance an over the real issue and
that's well it's a bit like it's a bit
to be honest it's a bit like the BET
which you said was with the devil all
right haha maybe I should get all hurt
and upset about you calling me the devil
my sensitive Little Skin can't deal with
it you're not a minority you're likening
me to the most evil creature ever
created I'm so distressed J I I want to
burst into tears and take you to some
Human Resources committee meeting not
right I don't care you can have a laugh
at my expense it's fine mate we used to
be a to do it and get away with it
without being arrested I am a
not I'm middle white onv are the words
prime minister they have an effect on
real people they do why W you but only
when you deliberately wrongly
disingenuously conflate two completely
different things then they do also I
think it's very odd that tweet from kemy
where she's saying it's wrong to make
jokes about murders but you can clearly
make jokes and score political points
about minority it's unfair it's not
right it's immoral to draw a link
between a point that Richi sunak has
made for literally months and then try
link that because the fact that B's
mother she has some nerve when she's the
one who introduced the trans guidance in
December which means being a politician
J we've got to bring an end to this part
of the debate you guys are all staying
to uh for the next segment where we're
going to talk about something less
contentious the royal family um but just
for the record just for the record if
from my position is is with the Prime
Minister if you are a woman you do not
have a penis that's it doesn't make you
transphobic and trans women deserve
absolute rights def fness in equality
right to the point they want to erode
the rights of being a woman sorry that's
just what I feel let's go to the out
let's go to
the welome back to on senstive Prince
Harry has swiftly retreated back to
California just a day he spent in the UK
he had one well apparently 30 minute
meeting possibly a little longer with
the King at clar house after his cancer
diagnosis was revealed this week Harry
did not meet his brother Prince William
he wanted to make that quite clear he
had no intention of meeting him and
tonight William returned to Royal duties
he spent this morning at winter castle
dispensing 50 honors and tonight he was
at a charity event where uh Tom Cruz
turned up and a pair of them were
parading for the cameras so quite
exciting evening there um to discuss the
Royals my pack is still with me um let
me start with you pear about this uh
given that uh Harry is fleeing back to
your country where you are now uh at a
rate of knots across the Atlantic are
you pleased that he's on his way back to
you would you like to keep him
there um well not particularly what one
thing I've noticed being in in London
and America and going in between um he's
not really liked in either country and I
think you know life comes with choices
and trade-offs and he made the choice to
trash his family and I I do think think
it's going to be tough for him to really
get in the position he was in before um
I I don't know how kind I would be to
someone that trashed my entire family I
know I know exactly related to them yeah
I know how kind I'd be I've actually
written about this for the New York Post
uh tonight I mean James what I would do
if one of my family one of my siblings
has spent the last few years trashing
the family on television trash my wife
trash my dad's wife trash my dad trash
my sister and so on I would dismember
them one limited time um and after they
i' severed all their limbs I would
probably incinerate them I think that's
disgusting I know but that's talking
about King Charles who has cancer right
now how can you be surprised I'm the
devil Devils do what Devils do here's my
point I mean metaphorically right what I
mean is I would be utterly conversation
about Harry who wrote a book a while ago
that's like been read by everyone like
who cares now was that just a book is it
why are we talking about this he wrote
well because he's just flown into to see
his father because his dad his own
brother his own brother refused to see
him and now you're doing a segment on
I'm bashing Harry like of course he
doesn't want to stay in of course he
doesn't want to stay in the UK whilst
you're bashing him on TV St out here as
well you defend him absolutely I think
he's brilliant I think he's been honest
with his journey hon he lies for his
back teeth no he hasn't yes he has what
are the lies listen them Li which ones
he's been exp he certainly wasn't lying
in that court case which court well the
miror court case right exactly well okay
you want to talk about that not really
but I'm actually a lot of the things
you're saying aren't true he's not lying
say he's a liar and his wife accused the
roal family of being racist that was a
lie there's no evidence for it they
never produced any evidence for it
caused enormous damage to the royal
family I think it's despicable AA can
you defend Harry do you think he should
be allowed back into the bosom of his
family I mean I could really care less
about the Royals to be honest altogether
but which in itself might be a problem
for them right because I think all this
does is diminish the stature of the
monarchy the more they're trashing each
other the more feuding and so on well I
would AR I think that you know I think
the people who've got the hardest job to
to to play for at the moment are William
and Kate because they are going to be
the eventual successes and I think that
you've got a 60% of the population now
don't care for the royalty don't really
want to keep funding it they're the
people who got to impress the rest of us
would I be more interested if they were
engaging with Prince Harry perhaps I
might I might start liking them again I
don't know about you I've said what I
would do if it was one of my family
right I'm not advocating that that
should happen I'm just saying if that
was my family that's what I'd feel like
doing I would be that right what do you
feel about this from a family point of
view yeah I think never mind the fact
that he's dashed all the way here to see
his father who's got cancer whereas
Megan hasn't once gone to see her own
father who's reported to be dying so
unfair 17 miles from her front
door you may not like it it's a
fact say the thing is I think it's
difficult to say what they should and
shouldn't do because I mean I know what
I would do in that situation but again
people change people can forgive but I
think we have to contextualize what
William is actually dealing with he has
a wife who's basically out of action he
has three young children he has to take
on more responsibilities you know and he
has to support his father and queen
Camila I can understand and he may have
to consider the possibility now and he's
probably reg co- Regent well not just
maybe stepping in to do the duties if
the king incapacitated or even if his
father you know was to tragically die
from this cancer which could happen then
he would be a king in his early 40s
right I mean yeah with three young kids
which serious time for William so I I
appreciate that on the his his top list
of priorities is not really being
interested in extending in all job by
the way but thing because the thing is
as well there's also the concern what if
Harry has Netflix cameras taping every
conversation that they have where is the
trust I would TR as I I can understand
that he has more important things to do
I personally I mean I'm a Christian so
you know I I I might send him I might
send him like a carrier pigeon being
like I still don't like you but here you
go all right let me bring me bring Paul
Paul back in is that
Christian let me ask let me ask Paul
what do you think of Megan Megan marle
in all this I I um I I think that
sometimes forgiveness is letting people
lie in the bed that they made you know
if someone robbed You're refering to I I
think if someone robbed me if somebody
robbed me I don't have to let them back
into my house I I can forgive you but it
doesn't mean I have to keep dealing with
you the idea will have to forgive his
brother after all he's done why should
he no one said he has to forgive his
brother the thing is as well what what
where is this definition of forgiveness
where have you got this definition of
forgiveness from what's your definition
of forgiveness to to let go of something
that someone has done not like you have
to let them back in your house you go
something that someone has done without
absolving them of the consequences of
doing that I'm just I'm absolutely ful
forgive someone who robed me you can't
be Baff I don't know why you're asking
about up to the front page of every
paper is about this story about Baff you
read the papers no the story is that
King Charles is unwell have cancer and
that we need to wish him our best
regards the story isn't oh Harry rushed
over why is there a news alert from BBC
telling us William won't be seeing Harry
whoes because actually it's quite
interesting that the young man who may
be king sooner than he would want to be
that his only sibling they don't they
hate each other so much they don't even
talk I do know for a fact can make the
William certainly hates Harry for what
he's done I think you can make the case
har Harry has um has stressed out his
father with the release of spare and all
of that and I don't I think it's a bit
ironic that he's rushing over to his
side when he's ill but he didn't really
care for his mental health when he was
Rel think that's to them no but I think
that's a fair point I think it's stupid
to to suggest you know what he had
trouble stay
inel Harry stayed in a hotel on this I
suggest next time given you're such a
fan he comes and stays with yous he's
more than welcome of course he is and
also Megan I will roll out a red carpet
oh of course you would yeah all
Hypocrites STI together all right thank
you